[Musique]
l'origine du nouveau coronavirus se
continue à faire l'objet d'une quantité
assez effarante de désinformation voici
un autre exemple qui mérite quelques
éclaircissements
ce chercheur américain aurait-il
fabriqué et vendu le nouveau coronavirus
à la chine libre 60 ans ancien directeur
du département de chimie et de biologie
chimique de l'université harvard a donc
été arrêté le 28 janvier dernier par les
autorités fédérales américaines des
conspirationnistes voit dans son
arrestation et son lien avec
l'université de wuhan
la preuve irréfutable de sa
responsabilité dans le déclenchement de
la pandémie actuelle rien à voir il n'a
nulle part dans cette vidéo relayée par
les conspirationnistes il est question
d'un virus quelconque ce qu'on y voit
est un procureur américain qui explique
la docteure libre a été accusé d'avoir
fait une déclaration fausse fictive et
frauduleuses sur ses sources de revenus
comme le chercheur et est financé par le
gouvernement américain pour ses travaux
à avril ils étaient tenus de divulguer
tout intérêt financier étranger ce qu'il
a omis de faire dans les faits le
chercheur recevait cinquante mille
dollars américains par mois de la chine
en plus de 150 mille dollars pour ses
frais de subsistance et un million et
demi de dollars pour la mise sur pied
d'un centre de recherche à hunan en
chine ou en voilà maurane épicentre de
la pandémie de kobe 19 la mention de
cette ville chinoise suffit pour
inspirer les conspirationnistes qui voit
dans le simple fait que le professeur
les bleus est en partie rémunéré par
l'université de technologie de one pour
le rendre responsable de la création et
la vente du virus pourtant les travaux
du chercheur bas ne portait aucune mans
sur l'étude de virus il dirigeait plutôt
un centre de recherche spécialisé en
nanotechnologie donc ce dont est accusé
le chimiste américain et d'avoir caché
ses liens avec la chine dans un cas
d'espionnage économique
deux citoyens chinois ont été arrêtés en
même temps que charles river pour plus
de détails sur cet autre théorie du
complot basé sur le nous
encore anna virus je vous invite à lire
l'article signé bouchra wathiq sur le
site web des décrypteurs et n'oubliez
pas de nous écrire et d'adhérer à notre
groupe facebook
salut
[Musique]